okay we've had a bit of a short break
from hatred mail due to breaking news
but i do want to get back to it what is
hatred mail
this is hatred mail between a renowned
infectious disease expert and the guy
who ran a fake university and bankrupted
a casino
i'm gonna have to go with the casino guy
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate
david pakman because america
and because freedom
got to love the new uh relevant
coronavirus
introductions um here is a very timely
hatred mail
related to the race to 1 million
youtube subscribers take a listen i'm
not a fan of david cuckold pacman
do incels write your headlines now shame
on you pacman
what's terrifying is that this guy
actually has an audience
imagine if he got to one million
subscribers
youtube would be ended park man
cooking what a joke does pracman even
know
how to fry an egg this is a very real
risk i like how
you know if pacman if pacman gets to 1
million subscribers i don't know things
could get really bad well
it seems to be more a matter of when not
if my goal is to get to a million
youtube subscribers before election day
this really would be a major
accomplishment what i was thinking back
to when we started the channel
and it took us like five years to get
our first hundred thousand subscribers
we are trying to get our last hundred
thousand well hopefully not the last
ever but the most recent hundred
thousand nine hundred to a million
um we're trying to do it in just about
three and a half months
and it would be a record and we've
already gone from nine hundred thousand
to nine hundred and seventeen thousand
and my prediction is there are going to
be many many hatreds very very upset
um sometime between i don't know
election day and the end of the year
between election day and christmas let's
say when we roll over
into the seven digits for our youtube
subscriber count
fight patriotism with something that
costs nothing just make sure you're
subscribed to the youtube channel
youtube.com
slash the david pakman show and i will
have updates for you right now we are
projected to reach a million
on december uh 23rd okay
so we've got to make up a little more
ground and reaching a million before
election day is actually on the table